I don't go to the gym very often.
It's a real workout.
Gotta come and shift the girls in.
So every single day we're doing this trek.
In the land of Africa.
Five year old cheetah triplets
Maathai, Murie, and Fossey
wait for keeper Dominique
to serve breakfast.
Okay, I see some kitties.
This is the auditory cue response.
Pretty much like their breakfast bowl
with the.
Hi. Hi, baby.
You're my girl.
And the thought, in my opinion,
is definitely our funniest cat.
She's kind of a sweetheart.
She does this thing where showcase
and spit at you, and then you feed her
and she's like, Oh, I never did that.
That wasn't me.
I'm very nice.
We don't play favorites, but she's definitely got a special place in my heart.
Buddy,
you got it for me?
Yeah.
Better than
I talk to the cats a lot.
It does help them to get used to you.
I wish they could talk back.
It would make our job so much easier
if there was something going on
and they were like,
My stomach's not feeling well today.
All done! You finished.
Nice job.
Now we will see the status
of the other two.
Nice Job Murie.
Murie and Fossey come in for their eats.
Okay.
You have a lot here that you dropped,
so I know.
With full bellies, it's time
to start the day. Hi.
Good morning.
These are my girls.
I love them so much.
They're so cute.
Look at them.
You got Mathai right here.
Take it a nice break.
I'm trying to learn their behaviors
so that sometimes
if they're having an off day or an off
week, we're able to tell those things.
Recently,
Mathai has shown some worrying behavior.
So she's had this gastritis for a while.
Sometimes she does have some flare ups.
She has been doing a lot of Riegert.
Sometimes it's like a small mountain.
Sometimes it's a big amount.
Lately, she's triggered
pretty much her whole meal, plus
some for like a couple of days in a row.
So that was pretty concerning.
One of those things that we are trying
to do with Mathai and her
stomach is give her some
antacids, my fingers are always crossed
and I'm always hoping for the best
that she will be a little
bit better.